es dauerte 40 jahre bis das geheimnis
der schweiz um die ohren fliegt 1955
unterzeichnen amerikanische agenten und
das schweizer unternehmen crypto ag ein
vertrauliches abkommen das das
ausspionieren der kommunikationsströme
von 130 ländern auf den weg bringt
jahrzehntelang kooperiert eine ganze
industrie
insgeheim mit dem segen des bundesrates
etwa bis heute politisch 1947 bricht der
kalte krieg zwischen den staaten des
westens und dem ostblock aus in diesem
kontext des misstrauens die die gefahr
eines dritten weltkriegs birgt sucht
washington um jeden preis nach einer
technischen möglichkeit die eigene
kommunikation zu schützen und die
nachrichten der sowjets zu entschlüsseln
dafür schien die usa auf die technik des
schweizer unternehmens crypto ag
[Musik]
winter 1955 der amerikaner william
friedman trifft bei seinem freund boris
hagel in zug ein
der amerikaner friedman leitet die
abteilung kryptologie des frisch
gegründeten geheimdienstes nsa hagel in
ist der chef von der krypto ag die
schweizer firma ist bei der
verschlüsselung von kommunikation auf
der höhe der zeit
sie verkauft ihre technik an praktisch
alle auslandsvertretungen der welt an
dieser technik findet die nsa gefallen
mit ihr könnte washington einen
technischen vorteil gegenüber den
feinden im ostring und boris hagel ihn
möchte seine maschinen gern auf dem
amerikanischen markt vertreiben
laut 2015 freigegebenen archiv berichten
der nsa schließen die beiden männer ein
geheimes handelsabkommen in der
kryptologie zusagt im auftrag der
amerikaner seine kunden in ost und west
manipulierte maschinen zu liefern
[Musik]
gm wolle quality auf encrypted
grafikeffekte mit diesen 1955
geschlossenen pakt können amerikanische
agenten die kommunikation von 130
ländern mit höheren
[Musik]
es ist eine frage von leben und tod
drei jahre nach ihrer gründung geht es
für die nsa ums überleben
[Musik]
1955 teilt sich die welt die
abendländischen demokratien im westen
der kommunistische block im osten am 5
märz 1946 unterzeichnen london und
washington den uk osl vertrag
der pakt sieht eine engere
geheimdienstliche zusammenarbeit vor
inmitten dieses strategischen geflechts
muss die schweiz sich entscheiden auf
welcher seite sie steht
[Musik]
exil in ultra clean ist ein treuer
freund vor allem aber ist ein
berüchtigter geschäftsmann
der geheimvertrag der ihnen friedman
bindet ist eine win-win-situation hagel
ihn endlich den amerikanern den
schlüssel zur dekodierung aus und erhält
im gegenzug lukrative verträge mit diese
vereinbarung ist ein gegen dienst an die
amerikaner dass die schweiz im zweiten
weltkrieg nicht überfallen wurde
verdankt sie zumindest teilweise den usa
zu dank verpflichtet opfer die schweiz
also ihre neutralität der beweis kommt
1956 mit pool schulde
der schweizer verteidigungsminister
unterzeichnet ein geheimabkommen mit dem
stellvertretenden oberbefehlshaber der
nato die schweiz bleibt neutral aber im
falle eines dritten weltkrieges würde
sie sich mit der nato verbünden
dieser amerikanische spionage und
geheimdienstexperte untersucht den fall
krupp ag seit über zehn jahren
die vertraulichen flitterwochen dauern
fast 40 jahre
doch 1992 bekommt das geheimnis friste
hans bühler ingenieur bei kripo wird im
iran festgenommen als er dem iranischen
verteidigungsminister verschlüsselungs
material verkaufen will
[Musik]
[Applaus]
teheran hat den verdacht dass das
material von krupp ag manipuliert ist
hans bühler wird vorgeworfen ein
schweizer agent zu sein
im auftrag der amerikaner er weiß nichts
also sagt er nichts
nach neuneinhalb monaten gefängnis kommt
der ingenieur frei michael grube der
leiter der krypto ag belegt schließlich
ein eine kaution in höhe von 15
millionen dollar zu zahlen
immer firma dbm zurück in kloten wird
hans bühler entlassen crypto ag fordert
die rückzahlung der kaution und leugnet
jede verwicklung in den fall
hans bühler beginnt an seinem ehemaligen
arbeitgeber zu zweifeln hat die
kryptologie etwa leichen im keller
die collector's edition ab riesen motto
während des kalten krieges mitglied des
schweizer nachrichtendienstes bestreitet
die existenz eines geheimen abkommens
orange vw beteiligung live
die gerüchte über eine zusammenarbeit
zwischen der krypto ag und der ns
erreichen die usa 1994 in der nähe von
washington aus coaching ist damals
journalist bei der baltimore sun als
geheimdienstexperte wirkt die affäre
seine neugier also kontaktiert der
angestellte der gruppe f liegt daher
nach zug wo er die direktion von krupp
trifft
vier stunden vor seinem rückflug in die
usa bekommt der journalist einen anruf
von einem ehemaligen mitarbeiter von
krupp der lässt um ein vertrauliches
memo eines geschäftlichen treffens von
angestellten der schweizer firma mit
einer gewissen nora makabi zu kommen
nach wochenlanger recherche die krypto
mathematikerin in diensten der nsa auf
[Musik]
die zusammenarbeit existiert bleibt die
frage welches ausmaß hatte sie zumal die
nsa durchaus freigiebig ist ein
vertrauliches dokument aus den
amerikanischen archiven unterstreicht
dass auch der deutsche geheimdienst bnd
von dem geheimabkommen mit krupp
profitierte germanwings
ja sticky ende der siebzigerjahre stellt
sich die frage nach der zukunft von co
die leiter finden einkäufer und zwar
deutschland in gestalt von siemens schon
immer haben krupp und siemens eine enge
beziehung die deutsche firma hält
anteile an kopftuch mehrere mitarbeiter
und ingenieure waren früher bei der
schweizer firma beschäftigt das deutsche
unternehmen steht in technischer wie in
finanzieller hinsicht zur seite diese
hilfe was selbstverständlich nicht
umsonst seit der nachkriegszeit hat die
schweiz breit will ich die augen
geschlossen um ihr gesicht zu wahren
doch was wusste sie über die
handelsverbindungen in der
internationalen spionage politischen
crypto hat alles daran gesetzt um diese
hässliche vergangenheit vergessen zu
machen und in bern schwindet die
erinnerung daran ag hüllt sich in
schweigen
denn die firma steht heute am rande des
ruins im januar 2018 spaltet das
unternehmen seine nationalen und
internationalen tätigkeiten in zwei neue
firmen auf
das entlässt mitarbeiter und ändert
seinen namen damit kann es jedoch kein
schlussstrich unter seine vergangenheit
ziehen
im übrigen ist ungewiss ob die
zusammenarbeit mit den usa nicht immer
noch weiter geht die affäre der
kryptologie ist zentral
sie steht am anfang vieler
partnerschaften zwischen schweizerischen
unternehmen und nsa
es ist daher kein zufall wenn die
eidgenossenschaft den amerikanern über
das departement für verteidigung und
swisscom seine strategischen standorte
zur verfügung stellt wie ilike wo die
schweiz ihre antennen privaten firmen
anvertraut hat wieder nsa nahestehen